Klasická optimalizace je klíčovým krokem v klasicko-kvantových algoritmech
jako je variační kvantový eigensolver nebo kvantové strojové učení.
Jenže minimalizace komplikovaných funkcí
ve vícerozměrných parametrových prostorech bývá obtížná.
Jmenuji se Victoria Lipinska a v tomhle videu prozkoumáme
klasické optimalizační rutiny pro klasicko-kvantové algoritmy.
Optimalizační problémy nejsou jednoduchý.
Jak roste počet parametrů, roste i počet možných
kombinací hodnot – a roste exponenciálně.
V šachu je například 64 polí
a každý hráč má 16 figurek; poté co každý hráč táhne jednou figurkou,
existuje 400 různých pozic. Po dvou tazích 72 084 pozic,
přibližně 9 milionů po třech tazích a přibližně
280 miliard po čtyřech tazích.
Pokud dojdeme jen ke 40 tahům, počet možných pozic
se odhaduje na přibližně deset na mocninu 120.
Zahrát dokonalou partii by vyžadovalo prozkoumat všechny možné
pozice, a tohle enormní množství znamená, že projít
všechny pozice jednotlivě je neproveditelné.
To se dá vyřešit rozdělením problému na dva menší podproblémy.
Nejdřív musíme určit, jaké rozložení šachovnice
se pravděpodobně objeví v dalších krocích naší partii.
Tomu budeme říkat náš podprostor zájmu.
A za druhé, pro daný podprostor musíme určit, který tah je nejlepší.
Tomu budeme říkat náš nejlepší tah.
V této analogii je počáteční prohledávání podprostoru zájmu
analogií našeho klasického optimalizačního algoritmu.
Jakmile je podprostor zájmu znám,
kvantový algoritmus má obvykle na starost nalezení nejlepšího tahu
v rámci tohoto podprostoru.
Začněme tím, že uvážíme jen jeden parametr,
theta, který parametrizuje účelovou funkci, jíž chceme optimalizovat.
Pokud funkci vykreslíme, vypadá třeba nějak takhle:
na ose X máme hodnoty parametru theta
a na ose Y je účelová funkce.
Mějte na paměti, že účelová funkce může být skutečnou finanční cenou,
kterou chceme minimalizovat, nebo – jak to bývá v případě variačního kvantového
eigensoleru – energií, kterou minimalizuje příroda.
Naším cílem je najít theta,
které odpovídá nejnižším nákladům.
Začneme s počáteční hodnotou theta a v každém optimalizačním kroku
najdeme nové theta, které dál snižuje náklady.
Zdá se, že docela snadno víme, kudy na grafu pokračovat, pokud ho celý vidíme.
Jenže obtíž optimalizace spočívá v tom, že ho nevidíme.
Dozvídáme se jen cenu – jen malý střípek celé skládačky –
jakmile vyhodnotíme funkci na zvoleném theta.
Takto optimalizace obecně funguje.
Optimalizátor vzorkuje parametry theta a počítá cenu.
Jak si dokážete představit, náhodné volení theta za účelem rekonstrukce
celé topologie funkce není příliš efektivní.
Chytré optimalizátory místo toho v každém kroku hledají
gradient funkce.
Optimalizátor tak ví, jakým směrem na grafu
postupovat, aby našel nejnižší cenu.
Jakmile je gradient nulový, algoritmus skončí
a minimum je nalezeno.
Toto minimum nemusí být globálním minimem.
Může jít o lokální minimum,
tedy nejnižší hodnotu účelové funkce v okolí,
ale ne napříč celým rozsahem theta.
V případě jednoho parametru to rozhodně možné je.
Čím víc parametrů ale máme,
tím komplikovanější funkce je.
Už pro dva parametry dostaneme plochu,
a pro čtyři ji už vůbec nedokážeme nakreslit.
Stejně jako v příkladu se šachem, reprodukovat všechny možnosti
se rychle stává nezvladatelným.
Vidíme tedy, že minimalizovat
komplikované funkce ve vícerozměrných parametrových prostorech je obtížné.
Přesto, abychom dostali rozumné výsledky, chceme, aby klasické optimalizační
rutiny byly zároveň rychlé i přesné.
Musí být také robustní vůči šumu,
který bude mít výrazný vliv na krátkodobé kvantové počítače.
Klasické optimalizační algoritmy lze zhruba rozdělit
do dvou tříd – přímé hledání a metody založené na gradientu.
Metody založené na gradientu potřebují informace o gradientu
funkce v průběhu optimalizačního procesu.
Ten lze buď vypočítat analyticky,
nebo aproximovat pomocí výpočtu konečných diferencí.
Metody přímého hledání informace o gradientu nepoužívají
a k minimalizaci účelové funkce využívají jiné strategie.
Mezi nejčastěji používané optimalizační algoritmy
v oblasti kvantového computingu patří tyto optimalizátory.
COBYLA znamená constrained optimization by linear approximation
a je to optimalizační algoritmus bez gradientu.
SLSQP je sequential least squares programming,
optimalizační algoritmus založený na gradientu.
Používá stochastický perturbační vektor
k simultánnímu výpočtu přibližného gradientu účelové funkce.
V prostředí bez šumu se ukázalo, že optimalizátory jako COBYLA
a SLSQP konvergují rychleji než SPSA.
Klasické optimalizátory mají vlastní parametry,
které můžeš nastavit pro konkrétní případy, třeba velikost kroku.
Ty lze obvykle najít v dokumentaci
ke konkrétnímu optimalizátoru.
Doporučuju ti podívat se na seznam odkazů níže pro porovnání
nejaktuálnějších klasických optimalizátorů.
Pojďme prozkoumat ještě jeden jev spojený
s klasickou optimalizací parametrizovaných kvantových circuit.
Jak jsme viděli dřív, vymizení gradientu účelové funkce může naznačovat,
že se optimalizátor ocitl na plató bez zajímavých rysů – tzv.
„barren plateau."
Barren plateau může mít mnoho příčin.
Gradient účelové funkce odpovídající kvantovému circuit
s náhodně inicializovanými parametry
exponenciálně klesá k nule s počtem qubitů.
Je to proto, že kvantový prostor, který optimalizátor prohledává,
se se vzrůstajícím počtem qubitů zvětšuje exponenciálně.
Způsoby, jak tento problém řešit, zahrnují snížení počtu parametrů
a tím i dimenze podkladového prostoru.
Další způsob, jak nahlížet na původ problému barren plateau,
může být problémově agnostická povaha parametrizovaného circuit
konfrontovaného s exponenciálně velkým parametrovým prostorem.
Navržení circuit způsobem přizpůsobeným danému
problému by mohlo být dobrým řešením.
Vedle exponenciálního parametrového prostoru, který barren plateaus vyvolává,
je mohou způsobovat i jiné fyzikální jevy:
šum a dekoherence přítomné v kvantových výpočetních experimentech,
celková expresivita parametrizovaného circuit,
nebo nelokálnost a míra provázání modelované účelové funkce.
Řešení těchto výzev zůstává aktivní oblastí výzkumu.
Teď, když jsme prošli hlavní součásti VQE,
shrneme algoritmus v příštím videu.